what else can you expect from a
trump-hating clinton-appointed judge who
went out of his way to make sure that
the result
of this trial was as negative as it
could possibly be
speaking to and in control of a jury
from an anti-trump area which is
probably the worst place in the United
States for me to get a fair trial
will be appealing this decision it's a
disgrace I don't even know who this
woman is I have no idea who she is where
she came from this is another scam it's
a political Witch Hunt and somehow we're
gonna have to fight this stuff we cannot
let our country go into this Abyss this
is disgraceful the whole thing is a scam
and it's a shame and it's a disgrace to
our country